i'm very pleased as we are now have two
European commissioners or to form of
young pink missions
i'm sure that at least both of you can
explain to us why Phillip is absolutely
right and by the European Union and
European Commission in particular
completely filled in Eva making an
attempt to have a common European
identity well can I say that one of the
eight basic skills that we're supposed
to give our youngsters by the time of
completion of compulsory education is
cultural sensitivity and cultural
expression but of course curricula is up
to their education ministers the
national education ministers to decide
and I wonder how many have included that
in the curriculum I really doubt it how
do you how do you include cultural
awareness in the curriculum I mean
languages would be one very important
thing they want no English person speaks
a foreign language I mean it's just one
of them is this they simply ignore the
other languages whereas Europeans I mean
continental Europeans are very good at
lac there's one exception of course I
lived in Paris for a while and people
told me but if you speak three languages
you're trying you'll if you speak two
languages you're bilingual and if you
speak one language you're French
yes terrible alright but anyway if you
have been in the European Commission for
what after 4 years 6 years 5 years 5
years right what have you done there you
know to help us to have a European
identity very little both culture well
the concept of culture and the concept
that your finish European Federation do
not help me as a practical politician in
confronting the three problems that
mentioned but perhaps we still have 45
minutes it will come to us the ribbons
if i may ask you are you a european i am
a Dutch citizen and therefore i am a
european you go all this nonsense about
feeling european is nothing compared to
reality european is a person who is a
legitimate subject of a country that
belongs to the European Union PhD
content I find that admirable in your
pragmatism but I simply don't agree
you're taking of the Norwegians no but I
if I had didn't have a urine past
European passport if by some ghastly
historical occurrence I was exiled to
Papua New Guinea I would feel I would
still feel European and I would feel
that because of the way I had grown up
whether that is a particularly good
thing I think it has many good aspects I
think it also has very many highly
problematic aspects but I don't think
it's just resides in a passport that is
politically an impractical approach a
totally impractical approach and it is
it one cannot hand feelings like that
politics deals with facts and and you're
being exiled to Venezuela and still
feeling European is not a fact that can
be handled in European politics
you